say hello to Colombia when I found out
that I got a place in this fellowship I
was in my pajamas a lot of refreshing of
my inbox to just check is it a good
email is it a yes or is it no that's
really the can the best news I've ever
had before
after the little dance and I talked to
my son at anything I really don't want
you to go but because you're going to
save the world so I let you go
[Music]
the scholars participating in the Obama
Foundation Scholars Program at Columbia
University are rising social change
leaders from around the world they are
inspired to address really complex
critical challenges in their communities
and in their home countries in Tunisia
we are in the middle of a transition
from dictatorship to democracy
mentalities and behaviors need to change
Vietnam is one of the most affected
country by climate changes we want to
raise the awareness we are completely
you to lead organization in India we've
taken on the mammoth task of advancing
gender equality
they're here for an academic year we are
providing them with experiences learning
opportunities to inform their work as
social change leaders we are inspired by
their fearlessness their tenacity many
of them they're doing work that is
challenging the status quo in their
countries in the work that I do I really
was struggling with the impact that we
will make and for me that's what this
opportunity represents to come together
be with people who have walked a similar
journey and empower one another
coming from Burundi to New York City
it's really impressive he just exceeded
that welcomes everyone it definitely is
one of the greatest cities on earth if
you can make it there you can make it
anywhere right like Frank Sinatra says
to walk across the Columbia campus it
was just amazed man as I came in I got
goosebumps
I just feel the privilege of being here
all the heritage of inventors
intellectuals writers there is this
unlimited access to knowledge to people
to cultures
[Music]
it feels like a community already and it
feels like family as we go along would
land together we'll grow together we can
solve big problems everybody called us
the Obamas struck me know I felt so
honored to be called like that
the name Obama means change to me to me
Obama means the community we come from
many different parts of the world so I
feel like I'm an open book I'm a dry
sponge I just kind of want to learn from
everybody my greatest hope is that I'll
learn new methods which I can use to
drive more social engagement development
doesn't reach the more excluded
populations and I like the fact that I'm
going to be able to have improved
leverage to be able to give back to our
country to what I'm doing in Tunisia
with my group it's really a new path
that's opening I think this is just my
dream come true
[Music]